[Musique]
dans cette cuisine centrale au collège
titans du port les agents du département
termine les préparations du jour soit
plus de 6000 repas
aujourd'hui les demi-pensionnaires
auront droit à un menu d'exception des
plats réalisés avec des produits péi
issue à 90% de l'agriculture biologique
on a une salade de museau mettre des
épices
bio pesit volaille pareil le poulet rôti
avec une strata douce pâte à cultiver
sans ces produits le tofu pareil les
légumes exceptionnellement mais en
culture ponot un cycle fouillons légumes
là c'est les oeufs et les légumes les
épices qui sont entièrement bio à salade
de courgettes pareil on l'a fait
exceptionnellement sa un gratin de chou
chou et c'est trop et à côté donc
toujours à biot un menu réalisé dans le
cadre du projet nutrition et santé
initié il ya trois ans un des collèges
cette action vise à sensibiliser les
jeunes aux dangers du diabète et à la
nécessité d'avoir une alimentation saine
et équilibrée mais davantage de sang sur
les différents aliments qu'ils
consomment tous comprennent d'où
viennent les produits qu'ils consomment
et comment est ce qu'on fait pour avoir
une alimentation équilibrée la nécessité
de consommer l'eau brute de consommer
des produits locaux et des produits de
qualité en également l'intervention la
filière volaille pays donc on a un
éleveur qui est parent d'un
établissement qui vient également et on
a un soutien de la ribère sur cet
atelier les collégiens rencontre des
professionnels de l'agriculture
biologique comprendre le fonctionnement
d'une exploitation ainsi que les modes
de production vont partie de cette
éducation à la nutrition et à la santé
quand vous ne savez rien encore bombarde
à sa bonne chose
aujourd'hui les enfants ne connaissent
pas qu'est ce qu'un produit bio pourquoi
le fait-on
ils savent ce qu'on leur donne à manger
comment ça a été très sympa
aujourd'hui l'important c'est de leur
montrer qu'on peut faire de commentaire
est ce que ça nous apporte l'affronter
avant tout et le guen est au coeur de ce
projet éducatif le département montre
son engagement à l'éducation à la
nutrition au sein des collèges et au
développement des filières de production
locale en favorisant l'utilisation des
produits pays dans les assiettes de nos
marmailles
[Musique]